قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
انه لا يمكن استبعاد ذهاب القوات الروسيه
الى كياف او الفيف في اوكرانيا واضاف ارن
الرئيس بوتين هو من يستطيع تحديد وقت
انتهاء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا وبشان الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا
اوضح ان الاسلحه المقدمه الى اوكرانيا
والمتخصصين الاجانب الذين وصلوا معها هدف
مشروع للقوات الروسيه وحذر من عواقب
الصدام اقوى جيوش العالم بانها ستكون
رهيبه ولن يكون هناك منتصر على الاطلاق
حسب
قولها لا تحارب نظام الاوكراني بل جيش
الناتو وتعداده ثلاثه ملايين و600 الف فرد
كما قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ان
العالم تغير بشكل جذري وتم وضعه حد لما
وصفه بالاملاءات الانجلوساكسونيه
صحفيه ان المؤسسات الدوليه سوف تتغير على
حد وصفه
لقد تغير العالم بشكل جذري كما لم اكن
اتخيله قبل بضع سنوات ليست هناك عوده الى
الوراء تم وضع حد لاملاءات الدول
الانجلوساكسونيه على الاقل في ضوء الاحداث
الجاريه والمحادثات مع الرئيس الصيني لا
اعرف ما الذي سيحدث بعد ذلك ولكن من
الواضح ان عصر الاتفاقيات الاقليميه
المقبل